salut aujourd'hui je vous fais une vidéo
en dehors du planning habituel parce que
j'ai besoin de vous dire une bonne fois
pour toutes où est ce que je vais être
et où est ce qu'on peut se rencontrer
vous me posez souvent la question dans
les commentaires des vidéos sur les
réseaux sociaux donc là au lieu de
répondants dispatcher ça devient
compliqué je vous réponds à tous en même
temps pour les dédicaces du livre votre
cerveau était extraordinaire j'ai déjà
fait la rochelle et quant au mois de
juin là je vais être le 30 septembre
seniors samedi prochain à la fnac de
mulhouse à partir de 15 et le 21 octobre
ce sera à lyon à la librairie decitre et
ce sera à partir de 16h je crois qu'il
ya deux librairies comme ça renseignez
vous pour savoir laquelle est la bonne
le 28 octobre ce sera la fnac de troyes
j'ai pas encore l'heure mais je pense
que la fnac vous le dire avant que je le
sache
le 29 octobre je serai à paris au grand
point virgule en spectacle et donc à la
sortie je dédicacerai les livres pour
ceux qui sont au mieux au spectacle
évidemment par contre je dis pas ça pour
faire de la pub puisque c'est déjà
complet leucate non ce sera à bègles au
cultura à partir de 14h30 et le 25
novembre ce sera toute la journée au
festival du livre de colmar ii matin
soir après midi parle tout le temps
évidemment il y aura d'autres villes qui
vont se rajouter je sais qu'il ya brest
et bordeaux sont en cours de discussion
ça des ventes quand est ce que les
librairies me demande ça dépend de quand
est-ce que moi aussi je suis disponible
mais je vous tiendrai au courant de tout
ça sur le site internet de vous les
points fabien lucas point fr et sur les
réseaux sociaux ça c'était pour les
dédicaces
ensuite en terme de spectacle je sais
que vous êtes nombreux également me
demander quand est-ce que je passe dans
votre ville sachant que de janvier à
juin j'ai déjà fait 100 villes est
souvent celle qu'on leur demande donc je
vais pas refaire de tourner tout de
suite en réalité là les seules choses
qui vont se passer il va y avoir les
mandragore au casino de paris où je suis
dessus c'est pas mon spectacle entier je
suis juste un passage
idem pour la suisse où je serai au gala
de montreux sur le gala de pierre cros
outre un numéro est par contre vous
savez peut-être maintenant je serai donc
à l'olympia le 22 septembre 2010 8
l'année prochaine ça c'est vraiment le
truc le plus ouvre qu'il puisse arriver
dans la vie d'un artiste et pour
l'olympia la règle du jeu est différente
c'est à dire est d'habitude c'est moi
qui fais des centaines de villes pour
allez vous voir là c'est à vous
vous organisez un an ça va pour venir à
paris les six stades at c du placement
numéroté donc plus vous prenez vos
places tôt plus vous pouvez avoir le
siège que vous voulez et surtout moi
plus je peux m'organiser à préparer des
trucs en fonction du remplissage temps
qu'on ait à faire des annonces est pas
une vidéo comme d'habitude je vais être
aussi sur d'autres évènements genre des
salomon des fois à des conférences je
sais que je fais le une conférence pour
le neuro planète qui se passe à nice je
peux pas vous annoncer tout ça tout le
temps sur la chaîne sinon je vais vous
saouler un moment donné donc n'hésitez
pas à faire un clic pour me rajouter sur
instagram ou sur twitter ou même sur
facebook et snapshot j'annonce toujours
ce genre de choses quand ça va arriver
et puis et pas que ça je postais pas que
des trucs intelligents sur les réseaux
sociaux loin de là d'ailleurs
donc ça déjà c'est un programme bien
chargé donc il ya moins de deux
spectacles en tournée en ce moment pour
la raison vous est donnée parce que j'ai
fait sans déjà représentation entre
janvier et juin
et aussi parce qu'actuellement vous
commencez à me connaître je suis encore
sur d'autres projets de trucs que je
vais vous annoncer bientôt concrètement
il ya trois choses que je suis en train
d'essayer de créer pour vous surprendre
pour me faire kiffer pour vous faire
kiffer avoir ce qui aboutira ou pas mais
ça ça me prend du temps bref la tournée
de dédicaces en tout cas je fais
vraiment ça pour venir à votre rencontre
gars n ya rien à payer c'est gratuit
même si vous n'avez pas de billet vous
pouvez venir il ya aucun problème c'est
un peu comme un mythe up améliorer et je
voulais un lien dans la description qui
reprend le parcours des dates de
dédicaces encore une fois il va évoluer
avec le temps avec deux dates qui vont
se rajouter et je vous mets également un
petit lien pour l'olympia oui c'était
une vidéo vraiment hors planning parce
que hors format et la vidéo habituels
sort demain sur la chaîne
il n'y a pas de souci on ne distingue
pas on ne relâche pas d'avoir une vidéo
comme ça je vous rappelle que moi je
vois toutes vos questions tout le temps
passer et que je vais y répondre
bien sûr évidemment merci encore d'être
toujours là aussi présent je vous mets
ici le petit cercle d'abonnements parce
que figurez vous qu'une personne sur
deux qui regardent les vidéos n'est pas
abonnés à la chaîne
et ça il faut que ça change abonnez vous
pouvez même depuis le smartphone à
bientôt ciao